years ago when they started this
censoring thing on Twitter and on
Facebook and on Google and so on I said
no no you have to you have to make
regulations it's a new industry every
human interaction is regulated by the
law and conservatives are going no they
must have freedom of speech I thought
absolutely not you know this these guys
are basically uh what do they call them
common carriers they're like the phone
company if I'm if I'm on the phone to
you and the operator comes on and says
excuse me sir you can't say that to Dave
and Dave can't spot you know no that guy
gets carried away because there's a
regulation against that we need to do
that now we're just catching up with it
I feel it's it's happening it may happen
in the Supreme Court session uh it's
certainly there's laws now in Texas uh
that have been supported by courts where
the court just said in Texas no you know
they don't don't have a right to violate
Free Speech it's a new thing almost
everything we're going through is
traceable back to the internet in the
same way that everything during the
Reformation is traceable back to the
printing press
host of the Andrew Clavin show on The
Daily wire as well as author of the
brand new book a strange habit of Mind
Andrew Clavin welcome back to the Reuben
report
great to see you then Andrew you've done
many things in your career
screenwriting many books daily wire but
you opened for me during the don't burn
this country book tour would you say
that was the highlight of the whole
operation and why even continue working
after that I I asked I struggled with
that question after opening for your act
I thought you know I'm now so covered in
shame that maybe there's no no
possibility of going on with any
self-respect at all but I've managed a
little bit how many books have you
written every time I bring you on I ask
you how many books and I'm still not
even sure how many books it's a lot of
books
well it's a lot of books the last book
when they published it they said it was
my 36 so I'm just going to go with that
wow I mean that that is really something
do you feel like each one when you
finish a book do you feel like it's your
last and then suddenly something the
well there's some more in the well or
how do you feel usually now the the only
time I ever thought of giving up was
after writing a book called Empire of
Lies which was a very difficult book and
a very emotional book and it really
wrecked me and I walked in and I said to
my wife that's it I'm done writing
novels and she said sit down and have
some dinner
you believe me even there wasn't even a
second where she thought that I might be
telling the truth it's kind of like an
addiction I can't stop you all right so
I want to get into the book and I'm I so
we just got a copy this morning so in
full disclosure I have not read it yet
but I've read the synopsis here and
obviously between big Tech and
billionaires and Espionage and all sorts
of stuff there's a lot that's relevant
to our political stuff of the day so
they'll be there'll be plenty for us to
talk about but first off you you like me
and so many others are a California
expat you are a refugee of what is now I
would say communist California you're
feeling pretty good people do people
know publicly where you live sort of
roughly yeah I'm in I'm in Virginia in
the DC area and uh yeah it's the
smartest thing I ever did I mean it was
it was the zombie apocalypse by the time
we left I was living I'm I was living in
the Hollywood Hills which is a very
ritzy neighborhood uh and by the time I
left I was patrolling my backyard at
night with a gun to make sure nobody had
moved in uh you know I had friends who
had found homeless people in their
Apartments friends who found them in
their backyard and you know it's nothing
against the homeless but there's nothing
compassionate about letting people live
on the streets it's not compassionate to
them and it's not compassionate to the
people who come to a city to find a way
of life that's uh you know Pleasant and
uplifting I don't think you can do that
when your city is overrun by people uh
not just homeless people but also
criminals who are not being restrained
in any way it's it's just amazing to me
it is absolutely amazing to me that a
state like California which is Paradise
I mean if you take the people out it's
just Paradise can be destroyed at that
level and yet people go on voting for
the people who destroyed it I once asked
Larry Elder why he thought that was so
and he said they just don't connect the
policies to the apocalypse uh it's all
policy I mean it was New York was like
that in the 80s and 90s when I lived
there and then Giuliani came in changed
the policies they called him a racist
every single day in the New York Times
he cleaned the city up and made it one
of the most beautiful cities uh at one
of the safest big cities in the world if
not the safest it took you know two
years to destroy all that work that was
kept in place by Bloomberg all those
years uh took just two years of
left-wing policies to destroy it it's
hard to understand like people will not
turn the corner I don't know whether
it's the feeling of virtue that leftism
gives them uh but it I I'm just so happy
to be out of that place it was
absolutely question by the time do you
see any hope because uh you know we had
a couple dinners in La before before you
left first wisely and then I I followed
a couple months later but all of our
friends left and from everything I've
seen in the basically the nine or so
months that I've been gone it's just
getting worse I mean what how should we
feel the people that leave like should
we feel oh maybe they will turn it
around or should we be hopeful or is it
just like you know what enough already
that's what you guys want then just keep
running with that
well you know I always hope it is one of
the United States I always hope that
it'll come back uh you know online and
in the past because so much of the
industry is uh creative there's
Hollywood and there's uh you know
Silicon Valley so these are people who
are creative they're capitalists they
like to pretend they're not exactly they
can make speeches at the Oscars about
not being capitalists but they're the
most capitalist people in the world and
so when their business gets undercut to
a certain degree you think that they're
going to come back and elect you know a
Reagan or uh you know even a
Schwarzenegger somebody to sort of
change things up the problem now is that
because we live in a world where we can
be connected like this like you and I
are connected right this minute there's
not that much uh difference if you leave
you can build an industry anywhere you
can run an industry from anywhere and so
my concern is that now people will
simply move uh you know to Nashville if
you go to Nashville everybody there is
from La uh you know people will simply
move to other places and just let the
place sink into the sea you think
eventually eventually the absolute
destruction of a brilliant economy
um we'll we'll back up on them you know
it just you think that people will only
stand it so long and yet the fact that
they have stood by well for instance San
Francisco one of the most beautiful
cities on Earth has been turned into a
hell hole is just amazing it is just
amazing so I don't know if it's going to
come back it's interesting because more
and more people are talking about what
is the United part of the United States
of America you know it's like I keep
saying it but I honestly feel like I
moved to a different country not to a
different state but to a different
country and and that I guess that leaves
us with the question of what makes us
United and I think there's a lot of you
know conservatives or whatever you want
to call broadly people on the right that
are just like there's nothing left
there's nothing left and that's it well
that is the thing conservatives do you
know that's kind of a kind of a
knee-jerk thing conservative it's over
it's all over I give up and all this and
and you know when when Roe v Wade was
overturned I just reminded people you
know that things can change amazing work
can be done it takes a long time it took
the left 60 years to take over our
institutions and bring the country this
low uh it's going to be a long fight to
take it back but it can be done my hope
is that we become more Federalist uh we
we let the states it be independently
become Laboratories of democracy try
different things and that as we do that
the good ideas will spread the
alternative scenario to that is we
become more Federalists we split apart
and eventually we find ourselves at each
other's throats uh but I but I hope
that's not going to happen in fact one
of the things that I hope will help is
the repeal of Roe v Wade I hope that
because of that cultures are going to
form that attract and repel people and I
think that you know right now it's the
economy people go places for the jobs
they go places to get away from the
homeless from the crime time but soon
people are going to go places to live
with other people like themselves and uh
as as one way of living works better
than others I think maybe more States
will turn over we'll see you know I
should tell you that here in Miami I did
finally see one person with the Charlie
Crist sign and I almost knocked on their
door and offered them free Mental Health
Services for a year it's like what are
you doing you're here in heaven and
you've got this Charlie Chris yeah
that's that's the big fear that they'll
bring California with them so we're
taping this uh just a little bit before
these midterms I mean are you basically
feeling like this you know conventional
thinking is Red Wave and the house and
the Senate they're going to get
everything back win a couple
governorships and then we'll reverse all
this Biden Insanity are you are you on
board conventional wisdom
no I'm hopeful but I'm not uh certain I
think we're going to win the house I
think the house looks pretty good uh but
the Senate is really uh tough and it's a
tough map for one thing and then there's
this the fact that
you know they keep blaming Donald Trump
for picking certain candidates Oz and uh
and um uh Blake Masters and guys like
that but the question is really is it is
that the problem or is it that the GOP
won't support those people they seem to
have pulled money out of Arizona a very
winnable State and I'm concerned that
maybe Mitch McConnell is thinking I'd
rather keep the minority and not have
these people come in and defy me and
rebel against me uh then let's let's
take the Senate back hard to really know
first of all it's always hard to know
what Mitch McConnell is thinking his
heart and where his interests lie but at
the same time I you know I also feel a
little bit like we're being gaslit the
polls are telling us no you know the Red
Wings back Nancy Pelosi saying oh we're
going to keep the house you know I
wonder if we're being gaslit a little
bit and maybe the Red Wave will in fact
appear in spite of some of the narrowing
polls but I I am concerned I'd like to
see the Senate go back I think Donald
Trump has been incredibly selfish with
his money uh he's got something like a
hundred million dollars that he has is
raised and seems to be keeping it either
for his legal fees or for his next
campaign and I think if you're going to
be the leader of a party then you've got
to pour some of that money into the
races that you in fact created you
always worry with Trump that he's only
thinking about getting personal revenge
for the people who didn't support his
stop the steel movement
um and I think that that's you know I
think Trump was a really good president
but I think he's been a bad ex-president
and I I'm I'm sorry about that I think
it's hurting the party which needs to
reformulate itself around some of the
things he taught them but can't do that
as long as he's getting in the way
instead of helping out uh is that your
way of saying you'd be sort of Team
DeSantis if if they have to make that
decision ultimately for sure I'd love to
see I would love to see DeSantis run and
yeah I would support him I wish that
Trump was the kind of person I mean this
is truly what they call wishcasting I
wish you were the kind a person who
would say I did my job I came in at my
moment and I changed things around which
he really did and now I you know we're
mean that the scientist will be my it
will inherit my mantle and move on
DeSantis is a kind of mini Trump there's
no question about it but he also was a
Statesman he's also a politician and one
of the things people like to say about
Trump is he's not a politician but
that's a profession you know politician
that's a profession and you know you
have to know how to do it you have to
know how to Wrangle people and pass laws
and not just pass executive orders that
can be swept away by the next god of the
pen I I know I can ask you about the the
walksters and the crazy lefties all day
long and we could do hours and hours on
it and I've watched your videos on
Instagram where you watch videos of them
doing weird things and all that stuff
but let me ask you one thing about that
because of someone as you mentioned you
lived in the Hollywood Hills you you
were in the Hollywood Machine as a
screenwriter and as an author I'm
guessing that you probably had
representation with some of those big
organizations and all that kind of stuff
did did it feel like it was going to
fall apart did you always sense that it
would fall apart and that way I don't
mean California specifically but but the
industry and just the way the culture
War has is just you know exploded
because they decided to not give us
anything remotely honest or reflective
of how people felt about the world
well I was warning about it for 20 years
you know I was saying that it's not you
know what we pour all this money into
some you know house race in Ohio but we
don't pour any money into creating
novels into creating movies into
creating the infrastructure that the
Arts need uh you know everybody is on
the right is celebrating the failure of
that movie uh Bros but it's one thing to
celebrate failures of movies that offend
your sensibilities it's another thing to
make your own movies and to also give
Awards uh to artists and encourage them
to artists and intelligent reviews to
artists uh some of that's happening now
it has been a long slow slog but yeah
you can vote for people all you want but
if you lose the culture this is the kind
of thing that's going to happen and I've
I've been thinking as I read the news
now and watching things one of the
greatest Arguments for Christianity is
the people who who lose it become
utterly evil I mean they're butchering
children in the name of a a weird
left-wing gender theory that has
absolutely no scientific backing uh they
keep you know people like Rachel Levine
you know who's to me a walking Monty
Python routine uh you know you know he
comes out he says things well the data
the data and nobody ever says to him
show me the date yeah show me that
because there was no data they couldn't
possibly be data uh supporting the
butchering of children but Andrew they
are the science that's why you're not
supposed to question that they are
science
no you know yeah you know when when uh
Vladimir Putin is screaming about the
Satanism of the West Vladimir Putin who
I think is a terrible terrible human
being and an awful dictator and a
colonialist and all these things but
he's saying that and I'm thinking well I
have to agree with him there he doesn't
have a point there so the culture is
really uh at a nadir and what I see
coming forward is basically a division
between people who opt to be human
beings and people who opt for a
technocratic world
um eventually they'll build synthetic
wombs and women will actually become
obsolete as as mothers and it's going to
be people who choose to say no you know
actually women are essential as mothers
that mothers are essential to our
humanity and we cannot farm this out to
these technocrats and that's what I see
in the future I'm hoping uh basically
they'll give me another 20 30 years if I
can get out of here and leave you guys
to younger people to deal with it but I
I do see that coming eventually yeah
well that's sort of why I was asking you
the question about what do you want to
happen to California or what do you
think will happen because I I agree I
think although we will remain United in
that I don't think we're going to have a
civil war in some sort of traditional
sense I just think the the things are
just going to diverge it just is what it
is that we've tried very hard saying
people to reverse the wokesters they've
made it very clear they're not going to
reverse and unfortunately the
institutions have shown that they don't
have the defenses uh to defend against
it so it's just going to continue to go
in that direction
yeah and there's the question of money
because what happens in leftism all the
time and I guess we can call this
leftism it's some kind of part of
leftism is the the middle class is
destroyed or moves away so you have the
poor and you have the powerful and
that's what what happens every single
time and that means that you don't have
a tax base and so in order to feed the
programs that keep you in power and keep
the poor from coming and burning your
Palace down uh you basically have to
shift money from other places and so
you're going to see a move by the
federal government to try and take money
from prosperous places like Florida and
like Tennessee and move it to places
that are dying of leftism like
California and that's when The Clash is
going to come and if that is prevented
if that kind of shift of money is
prevented then I don't know I just think
things fail you know leftism fails
everywhere it's tried Scandinavia Russia
you know Cuba everywhere it's uh tried
it's a much harder it's much easier to
enslave a little island like Cuba than
it is to enslave westerners and people
who have a history of Freedom listen I
can tell you in the very International
City of Miami that I'm in you meet a
couple Venezuelans and a couple Cubans
and they will tell you uh what that what
that oppression was like well let's
shift to the book a little bit because I
as I said we just got it this morning
um
well I want to read just a uh one of the
bullet points on this because I thought
this was just fascinating as I was just
reading it uh right before we started uh
the world of big Tech is full of
eccentric characters but shamanic
billionaire Gerald Byrne may be the
strangest of the bunch the founder of
Berner a global social media platform
burn is known for speaking with vague
profundity and for dabbling and esoteric
spiritual practices he wears his hair in
a long black ponytail to reveal a large
flower tattooed on his neck he's
universally admired as a Visionary a
philanthropist and a devout husband and
father and every person who gets in the
way of his good work seems to die now
there's a lot there because obviously
I'm reading that the imagery of of Jack
Dorsey from Twitter is popping in my
mind with his beard and weird things
there's all these sort you know we've
got Elon Musk and we've got uh the
Amazon guy Jeff Bezos so all you know
there's this weird billionaire class of
these sort of strange characters
um how do you come up with a character
like this and who's it really based on
oh I couldn't possibly comment on that
uh but yeah you know I think one of the
things that happens to billionaires and
I've noticed this I've known a lot of
billionaires and they never stop talking
they never listen to a word you say and
they basically the principle is if
you're so rich why if you're so smart
why aren't you a billionaire why should
I listen to you when I have a billion
dollars and they sit around and they
really do make these big plans for the
world without anybody ever saying to
them you know
you invented a gizmo that made you a
billionaire and that's great and
congratulations but what on Earth gave
you the license to control the lives of
other people you know why why are you
flying to Davos in your private jet to
discuss how much gas I can use in my
Volkswagen you know right it's like is
it it's a complete it's a complete
disconnect and so what I wanted to do
the character of Cameron winter who
first made his appearance in When
Christmas Comes which we we did talk
about that was the original his original
story uh and he really uh kind of caught
my imagination and for the first time in
my life literally I thought here's a
character I could build a series on uh
because he was he's a very complex guy
with a past that's different than his
present and a future that he hopes will
be different than his past he's kind of
moving in a certain direction and he's
surrounded by this world that's really
kind of coming apart at the scenes so
it's the story of a man who's trying to
learn to be a good man uh after a pass
that's not so good in a world that's
collapsing in a world that cannot Supply
him the values he needs to move forward
and that to me just seems like an end
endlessly fascinating idea so I wanted
to put him up against one of these guys
where where he basically you know the
people who get in his way get canceled
but they get canceled forever you know
and so and so you have a guy who's kind
of looking who has done some of this wet
work in the past he's done some of the
the kind of evil things that people have
to do in government uh and in Espionage
and now he's thinking no you know I want
to live a better life but he notices
that the people around him are starting
to do those kinds of things almost
without any conscience at all so the
basically this is two men facing off I
mean if you picture it as a movie poster
it would just be these two faces looking
at one another uh Gerald Byrne and this
kind of English Professor that's what he
is now and he keeps telling people
that's what I am I'm an English
Professor but he's an English Professor
with a past that's much more difficult
so I wanted to put them off against one
another a person who believes in the
traditions of the past the art of the
past the culture of the past is trying
to build a personality based on some of
those traditions and values against a
guy who basically has reached a point
he's not a bad man he's just a man
insulated from the uh
um from the consequences of his ideas
and so I wanted these guys two guys to
face off and they face off with a woman
between them who was really one of the
best characters I think I've ever ridden
just he's just an actual good woman who
is married to this guy Gerald Byrne and
the question is how much of what he's
doing is she you know it's so
interesting that you mentioned uh the
way these people become insulated and
how they think uh because you know I've
gotten to know Peter Thiel quite a bit
and I heard him give a talk once where
he said that when these guys go to Davos
and to these you know massive meetings
where they're in essence discussing how
to organize the world he said that no
one's ever representing the individual
that it's always that oh it's a
corporation that's there and it's a bank
that's there and it's this conglomerate
that's there no one is representing the
guy who has to put the gas in the
Volkswagen no one so I would say he
probably is the maybe the exception to
the rule on that sort of thing yeah but
to to you know broadly speak it's like
what does what does Bill Gates why does
he have the right to tell us we have to
eat bugs while he's now the largest farm
owner in the United States
it is it is quite remarkable remarkable
the Detachment with which they exclude
themselves from their own rules uh you
know there is a reason they built
Guillotines in the old days and I think
that these guys kind of exemplify that
reason I I'm very deeply opposed to
political violence but giving these guys
a good swift kick in the backside would
not be a bad idea you know not I don't I
don't want to kill anybody but just to
get just to humiliate well now I know
what clip Media Matters is going to find
of today's show
well done Andrew
Bloodshed I just want my footprint on
this she did their pants
do you find that sort of amazing though
really like that just at a granular
level that these people have now
infiltrated every part of our Lives
whether whether we know it or not
whether it's because you buy all your
stuff on Amazon or because Gates owns
all the land or whatever it might be
that we're all holding this in our
pocket and God knows who's in charge of
this thing at this point
you know there are two things that keep
me from being amazed one is all
throughout history there have been
people like this people who think that
have these Global ideas and they think
that they are going to impose them on
the world and the world's going to be a
better place always a disaster every
single time but there's also something
else the technological age has raised
people who are essentially autistic uh
to the level of kings and these are guys
who are completely detached from the
inner life of other human beings I I
don't know if you saw that clip of
somebody at Davos saying we can make
medicines that we can track after you
take them and he said imagine the
compliance well that's a guy who has
lost all sense that you and I have inner
lives that are equally important to his
and in fact the homeless guy on the
corner has an inner life that's equally
important I think I think you're talking
about uh Yuval what's his name Yuval
Harare I think is his name yeah Noah
I don't think that was the guy in the
clip but he's one of these people
definitely uh you know who who they can
all understand the inner lives of
animals they love animal but they can't
understand the inner Lodge of people and
I think that the technological age we're
living in Has Lifted those people to new
heights they've always been around but
now they they are the guy it's not the
guy who dug an oil well and then made so
much money that he could hire build an
oil business it's not that guy it's not
the guy who came uh from overseas and
built a movie studio and had his hands
on the film and then could hire other
people to do it these are guys who deal
with little you know bows and ones and
really have never had the experience of
another human being mattering to them at
the level that people have to matter to
you when you are in charge of large
areas of humanity it's funny do you
remember a couple months Back when Mark
Zuckerberg was introducing the metaverse
to everybody and he's in the commercial
himself and he's walking into this
alternative universe and it's like first
off you're the guy who runs Facebook who
has screwed up so much of how we feel
about each other these days and has
caused parents to hate children and you
know friends to turn on each other and
everything else you also seem like an
automaton you don't even seem like a
full human and now I'm gonna follow you
into your crazy alternate universe and
yet we know that a huge percentage of
people are gonna do it
yeah well you know one of the things
that I think is important to realize is
that many people many more people than
you think are mentally ill a larger
percentage of people oh I think it's
quite a high number actually it's a high
number and it wouldn't surprise me I'm
on Twitter
well there you go I mean it really is
interesting that they're not they're not
dealing with life in a very uh connected
way you know all this stuff about the
Golden Rule you know doing to others and
see what happens love your neighbor you
know as yourself that kind of idea uh
there's a reason for that kind of idea
it's not because you're a good boy and
you go to heaven if you love your
neighbor like yourself it's because it
connects you to reality it connects you
to the world and to this infinite uh
pattern of you human beings interacting
with each other which is all of the joy
of life you get it in your family with
your children you get it in your you
know in your marriage but also you get
it in your neighborhood and all of that
stuff is being dissected and destroyed
by people who do not experience the
inner lives of others because they are
essentially at least morally I don't
want to make it a medical diagnosis but
morally autistic and I think as
Zuckerman is a Zuckerberg is a great do
you think there's a way to reverse that
I mean I do sense that there's going to
be a real anti-technology Revolt at some
point within the next decade I mean it's
just so obvious the the level of
censorship and Shadow Banning and don't
talk about Hunter Biden laptop you can't
question this election you can question
that one like the all the asymmetries of
it and inconsistencies I think on top of
just the general endless scrolling and
what it's doing to the dopamine in our
brains and all of this stuff I sense
there's going to be like a real push
against this do you think that that's
probably right
completely agree with that and the
reason is because it's happened in the
past during the Industrial Revolution
these factories were built they
destroyed families suddenly children who
used to stay home and help you with the
farm were going off to the cities to
work in the factories and never coming
back uh families were Torn to Pieces
women were deprived of all the home
industries that made them a powerful
economic Factor that's why feminism
starts to rise at exactly that moment
because suddenly women who were called
the disc staff because they made all the
clothes you know that was a tool you
used for making clothes that's a huge
industry they made the food they they
planted Orchards and all these things
suddenly they had nothing except raising
children and they had lost their place
in society well over time governments
started to say Hey you know actually you
can't put a six-year-old or an
eight-year-old in a blacking family you
know you can't have children working you
can't destroy everything in your wake
just to make a bundle and they started
to regulate it years ago when they
started this censoring thing on Twitter
and on Facebook and on Google and so on
I said no no you have to you have to
make regulations it's a new industry
every human interaction is regulated by
the law and conservatives are going no
they must have freedom of speech I
thought absolutely not you know this
these guys are basically uh what do they
call them common carriers they're like
the phone company if I'm if I'm on the
phone to you and the operator comes on
and says excuse me sir you can't say
that to Dave and Dave can't explain you
know no that guy gets carried away
because there's a regulation against
that we need to do that now we're just
catching up with it I feel it's it's
happening it may happen in the Supreme
Court session uh it's certainly there's
laws now in Texas uh that have been
supported by courts where the court just
said in Texas no you know they don't
don't have a right to violate Free
Speech it's a new thing almost
everything we're going through is
traceable back to the internet in the
same way that everything during the
Reformation nation is traceable back to
the printing press and so this is
something we we have to Grapple with and
come to terms with I I I'm hopeful just
like you that as a generation grows up
that is is
um knows this stuff better than the
older generation they'll start to say
well we'll curtail it here we're going
to stop and here we're going to do this
this way and it'll start to work out in
a better way than it is right now so do
you think that this moment that we find
ourselves in between the big Tech
craziness and now just all the exposing
of all of the political nonsense uh that
this is sort of inevitable that that
maybe 20 years of the internet was going
to have to get us to a place like this
so that enough of us could have that
Awakening and then get to the other side
of it that it was going to happen no
matter what that's exactly what I think
and I think that like so much is ending
right now I said this when Donald Trump
was elected this is not the beginning of
something it's the end of something that
will lead to the beginning of something
you know it's the end of the post World
War II era it's the end of the Reagan
Era it's the end of the baby boom Epoch
the Baby Boomers are all gonna die I'm
just hoping they won't take me with them
when they go you know and and it is the
invention of this brand new thing I mean
when you think about the invention of
the printing press and then you have the
Reformation of the 30 Years War you have
The Counter Reformation you have the
Inquisition you have all this violence
coming about simply because suddenly
someone can read the Bible and say you
know what I don't think the pope is
right about this you know some clown in
Germany can read the Bible and say you
know actually this doesn't actually
sound like what the pope is saying
that's that's how things fall apart and
that's what's happened here essentially
uh what coverage called the pleurisy the
you know this chattering classes uh have
suddenly had their Monopoly of
information taken away from them and so
the Counter Reformation is basically the
Inquisition that's going on is as you're
thrown off Twitter you're throwing off
Facebook Google's only going to show you
climate change uh information that
agrees with what the elites want you to
think didn't work in the Inquisition
didn't work in the counter it's not
going to work now eventually this is the
democratization of information we're
going to learn how to handle it we're
going to learn how to sort
misinformation from information
basically if it's coming from the
government it's misinformation and then
everything else is open the question but
but you know we'll learn to sort it and
we'll stop them from censoring us and I
think ultimately yeah that'll smooth out
let me ask you one uh someone on the
personal side of how we both go about
doing the political thing relative to
what you're talking about
um it's getting harder and harder to
find people on the other side that are
that are willing to have these
conversations I would say it's almost
impossible at this point
um are you able to find anybody to talk
to to take the Counterpoint and do it
without you know murdering each other
uh two two in two ways I'm able to do
this first of all older people can still
do it I still have discussions with
older people where you know because I I
have a lot of uh old liberal friends who
are like what happened to you you know
and I'll sit down and I'll explain to
them what happened to me and they'll go
oh yeah I kind of feel some of that too
even though I'm more you know I'm wedded
to my Democrat Party or whatever uh you
know we have those conversations we have
them in a friendly way an intense way
somewhat sometimes with a friendly way
but the other thing is is that there is
now going through the left the Democrat
the central left
they're quietly appalled they're quietly
appalled by some of this gender stuff
they're quietly appalled by what's
happening in schools they understand
that this uh shutdown over covid was a
big mistake uh and and really hurt them
they have kids they see their kids being
hurt and they'll say it but they're
afraid and that's what we have to get
past that's why the daily wire you
anybody who's willing to bring on
alternative voices and who's willing to
take the heat is so important because
the people who don't have our platforms
the people who aren't protected as we
are by the First Amendment and can be
fired by HR for not agreeing you know
with their stupid uh policies those are
the people who are afraid we need to
bring them out into the open we need to
let them know that they shouldn't be
afraid we need to fight the powers uh
that make them afraid and then I think
we'll be able to talk again do you think
that that fear thing is a uh is maybe
connected to a spirituality uh deficit
within liberals let's say I mean you you
have an interesting uh spiritual journey
if you were born Jewish you're Christian
but that liberals who tend to be more
secular they then some for some reason
you could sort of see it with covet they
were all about fear basically overnight
and now that's sort of permeated through
everything yeah there's just no question
about this this is the other thing
that's always at the core of everything
you know we we have been taught to think
about history without God in it so you
know we'll say God is dead you know and
then and that's a perfectly Fair
statement to make comparing the Middle
Ages to the 19th century but you have to
understand that what that means is he's
dead in our hearts he's dead our
churches are are failing us it doesn't
mean he's actually dead and so we have
to start thinking about what it is we're
doing here as human beings because if
what we're doing here is trying to live
as long as we can before we die uh then
when you know Jake Tapper comes on CNN
and says no you must be afraid you must
be fearful uh then yeah we should be
fearful because as as Andrew Cuomo uh
said what's what could be worse than
that death but when we start to say no
we're actually part of a greater
spiritual journey and sometimes just
like the guys who you know invaded
Normandy beach sometimes we have to face
death and even accept death as part of
that Journey then then you have a very
different way of looking at things you
know I'm I'm fortunate that I'm like a
you know a chattering guy like you I'm a
writer and all that stuff I don't often
have to dodge bullets uh or run onto a
beach being sprayed by machine guns but
I wouldn't I wouldn't for one second
restrain what I say because people might
cancel me I know that because I've done
it I've been kicked out of Hollywood
basically yeah uh and and you know I I
would never ever do that not because I'm
not you know it's not because I'm brave
it's because in God I'm fearless uh as
long as I'm in God as long as I'm
centered in God I know that I just have
to do what's right and I will I will be
okay in the long run even if that long
run is eternal and not within my
lifetime so we we've yes when you lose
that when you lose that hook and to
something bigger than yourself
everything becomes fear how can it be
anything else because we're all just
these fragile little people who are here
today and gone tomorrow and if we're not
part of something Eternal what's the
point of ever putting your head over the
edge of the trench it's so interesting
because when people come up to me like
at the store or something and they'll be
Dave it's so you're so brave you're
saying all the things that I want to say
and I always have two thoughts at the
exact same time one is well hey I'm not
being shot at I'm not I'm not in war so
I'm not brave to that extent that it's
just not a real comparison and B I don't
know that it's bravery that causes me to
say the things that I believe I
sometimes I think it's just I'm like I'm
nuts I guess maybe I'm just kind of nuts
like I don't know everyone seems to be
afraid of this thing yet I seem to be
one of the people doing it like I don't
know maybe I'm crazy I don't know if
that makes you Brave I I always remind
myself that we do have an extra layer of
protection because we speak for a living
so we're protected by the first
amendment in ways that a guy who works
in the clothing industry or the car
industry is not protected in the same
way and they can say to him you didn't
sign the HR paper saying that you know a
man can become a woman right right
you're fired so so we we're a little bit
uh more protected but yes I also think
that that is what the times require so
it's People Like Us who uh who remain
because that's what the time required if
you're not if you if you're not able to
do that you're not going to be doing
what we're doing what do you think of
reformation for the Democrats your old
friends that you can talk to what would
it look like like what do you think
could happen over there that would
reverse the insanity right like to me
right now there's a decent fight on the
right there's like okay are we going to
go the Trump route are we going to go
the DeSantis route I think there's good
Arguments for both either they're going
to have to figure it out on the DL or
the or it's going to happen out publicly
and I think either one probably is fine
um but on the left it's hard to figure
out like what are you people going to do
with this this monster that is there
yeah I see I think that the the delusion
that the left is living under the nice
people on the left and there are many
many of them many good people on the
left the delusion is that yes the people
who are butchering children may have
gone too far but there is a version of
this where that doesn't happen right and
and that's not true yeah I mean it's all
one it's all one thing and and so uh
look there is there is something called
liberalism which may be uh supports more
of a welfare state for instance than I
would support I would think I would like
to see more things done by private
Charities I would like to see the Great
Society dismantled I think it's been a
disaster I think that all of the stuff
that people are attributing to the
police which have not who have nothing
to do with it uh really can be
attributed to the Great Society which
destroyed black families and made black
people dependent and basically
um funded all kinds of bad behaviors
that have destroyed black communities uh
you know I'd like to see all of that go
away but I can imagine a liberalism this
sort of like Frederick High Frederick
Hayek says you know we need a little bit
of a of a um welfare state so people
won't be afraid to take chances and take
risks and all that stuff uh if you can
create recreate that liberalism that was
the liberalism that I grew up with
um yeah then you'll have sanity on the
left again but either they're going to
follow these people
to the point where their children are
taken away from them because they won't
let them wear a dress are they because
they won't cut a
healthy girl's breasts off
um you're either going to follow those
people or you're going to have to side
with us and it's going to be tough you
know that's that's another reason by the
way where I think I I have real
misgivings about Donald Trump because
he offends the sensibilities of those
people and the people on the right who
say oh Mean Tweets Mean Tweets well you
know human beings are are not logical
creatures they don't necessarily say
well that policy is working therefore
I'm going to take this guy who I can't
stand uh and and vote for him uh you
know politics is partly Showbiz and
you've got to be able you've got to be
appealing to these people and convince
them I think they vote for Ron DeSantis
I think there are a lot of Democrats who
vote for Iran DeSantis once they saw him
I'm getting a lot of that on the DL from
you know people the few that'll still
talk to me that you know couldn't vote
for Trump or some of them maybe did but
it was Private that they could do do the
DeSantis move you know it's interesting
when you mentioned that about the
welfare state and what it did to the
black family and all of that stuff but
but you are you know the Hayek argument
of like there could be some sane version
of this this is where I always quote a
great line from teal he always says you
know if any of it worked I wouldn't be a
Libertarian but but the human part of it
once you get humans into the machine
this is Thomas Sol has talked about this
a lot you know you tell the government
that their stuff isn't working and they
tell you we need more money for it and
then it just expands the stuff that's
not working yeah they never give up
their power you know uh Jeremy boring
the guy who runs the daily wire uh he
called me up when they said 15 days to
slow the spread and he's a much younger
man than I am and he said they'll never
open again and I laughed and I said you
know 15 days is not such a bad idea and
I had to go back and say you know you
were basically right yeah they will open
again but two years 15 days it becomes
two years is not acceptable but that is
the way the government now works didn't
used to be like that but it's the way it
works now and we seem to be a huge
percentage of US seem to want more would
want more of it thank you sir may I have
another just more of the control and
they would there's a bizarre I honestly
think that probably something like 40 of
the people it might be something around
there would be glad if all the craziness
came back and I think that maybe is
connected to a spiritual thing that
they're they're just living for nothing
at the moment or something
well it goes back to what I said before
about like connecting with the inner
lives of other people which is kind of
what I do for a living but it's also
like my spiritual practice is
understanding that I'm not talking to a
face I'm talking to a human being whose
inner life is just as important you know
when you lock people in a room and
they're suddenly saying oh you can be
educated online you can work online you
can see everybody online you can't you
just can't and it's hiding away from
life and I think as we said before I
think there are a lot of people who are
happy to hide away from life because
they don't do life well and I think that
that's why so many people are on
antidepression so a huge number of
people think that they can drug their
way to happiness uh it never occurs to
them to say that it does occur to a few
of them but it doesn't occur to enough
people to say you know what that's not
happiness taking a drug and feeling
better is not happiness I've got to find
another way to do this uh so that I'm
still a human being and and like I said
before I think in the end we're going to
divide along those lines it's not going
to be left and right it's going to be
human or inhuman it's going to be
drugged or doing yoga and spiritual
practice it's going to be you know
cooking a baby in a in a box and then
having it raised by machines or at uh
you know daycare or whatever and saying
no we've got to form families and we
don't form families we're nobody we have
no government of our own uh and that's
where I think the division is going to
come so actually I was gonna this was
going to be a complete non-sequitur but
then you you mentioned family so you get
me you get me to the ending nicely
because we've talked about this a bit
before but most of my audience knows
your son Spencer Cleveland uh who I just
got his book today too it's downstairs
um and uh Spencer got married he happens
to be gay he got married to a dude a
month or two ago unfortunately I
couldn't go because Justin was born that
day literally so I didn't get to upstage
you in the speech that's what I heard I
was I was I was I was so happy I didn't
have to follow you on I was like the
last thing I wanted to do
um but you're a conservative he lives in
Nashville in Tennessee Works Josh works
at the daily wire these are
conservatives they're not supposed to
like gay people you're supposed to
disown your son blah blah blah blah blah
and yet I sense it was a pretty great
day and life is good and it wasn't a lot
of hatred it was it was a lovely day and
and you know and obviously I love Josh
and I'm thrilled to have him become part
of my family I'm also thrilled to have
my son grow up in a time when he doesn't
have to skulk around or worry about the
law coming after him for who he is but
that doesn't mean we shouldn't be
allowed to talk about uh things without
being called names you know there were
people at that at Spencer's wedding who
think that gay marriage is the end of
the world they came to the wedding
because they love Spencer and they love
Josh as I said in my my toast I said you
know you didn't lay your principles
aside you prioritized your love once you
do that once you say I understand you
know that that you're a person and you
have to have want to seek a happy life
and you're not responsible to me as long
as you're not hurting anybody then you
start to talk about what what is you
know obviously is to just have a sign
outside you're doing this is Love Is
Love is as stupid as it's possible to be
there's obviously a difference between a
man and a woman and a marriage and two
men in a marriage or two women in a
marriage we should be able to talk about
that we should be able to talk about uh
why nature gives us men and women as a
model I think it does you know I think
we are created male and female we are
men and women are meant to be together
the fact that not everybody can
participate in that but models uh but
sees that model as a good thing is I
always thought was kind of a positive uh
development I I do too I don't know if
you happen the first thing that I did uh
with Jordan Peterson as part of daily
wire I did like a two-hour sit-down with
him discussing just this and people
people were like oh it seems like Dave's
saying somehow that gay marriage isn't
equal and it's like no but there is a
thing that Western Society has been
built on and you want to give room for
decency and respect and and the things
that are a little bit on the margins but
we should be able to talk about that at
the fact that you just said and I know
because I spoke to Spencer and Josh
before the wedding that they invited
people who are not personally okay with
gay marriage it's like do you think that
those people left maybe a little bit
more open-minded probably as opposed to
just being called homophobes and not
invited then which way would they be
tilting well exactly and and it's so
dumb I mean it's so dumb if you're if
your idea of your philosophy is there
are people who agree with me and then
there are people who are racist sexist
phobic of some sort you're an idiot I
mean you're an idiot you know like all
of us have ideas but enough about Kamala
Harris yeah
that's beyond idiots uh but but no I
obviously if you're going to have a
conversation you have to make room for
other people's ideas even if those ideas
make you angry you have to be able to
see what people of Goodwill some people
are not people of Goodwill but people of
Goodwill disagree and you have to let
them disagree and you have to see what
they have to say I think that Christian
right has a lot to say about gender
that's not being heard that we should
listen to because obviously the opposite
of what they're doing is a mess but but
that doesn't necessarily mean I have to
set people on fire when I disagree with
them uh it doesn't mean that I have to
destroy them or or hate them and and I
think in in this case I mean this was
something I was on board people always
say that I changed my mind because of
Spencer but that's just a simple untruth
I always felt this way that that being
gay is a very specific thing it's not a
choice people make people have died and
been imprisoned because they were gay
it's not you know it's not something you
wake up in the morning or you're a
little kid and think I want to grow up
to be gay that's not the way it works uh
it is something that people are and it
comes with uh you know a lot a lot of
ramifications that are worth talking
about between people of Good Will I mean
it just when I hear Christians say well
it's okay as long as they're celibate
yeah it's okay with me as long as you're
celibate yeah
oh how about you try that and get back
to me you know I think I I think just a
little bit of uh you know I hate to use
the word love like it it matters but it
does matter you know a little bit of
love between us a little bit of
compassion for each person's uh
sensibility and then you can start to
trust one another to discuss things uh
at a level Beyond bile you know level
Beyond slogan earring and uh hatred uh I
think these are important issues I think
gender is a hugely important issue I
think it's a hugely complex issue but
that doesn't mean you take a 16 year old
girl and cut her breasts off you know I
mean you gotta you have to have Decades
of conversation and philosophy before
you even think about making moves like
that and we just don't do it anymore
because our press is so corrupt and our
academies are so corrupt uh and our
government and our businesses are so
corrupt that they basically shut the
conversation down
Andrew you are a true professional who
knows how to close down an interview
you're a great gal by the way and a
strange habit of mind is on sale right
now we will link to it down below and uh
I hope to see you soon my friend always
great to see you today if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell